you have to embrace pain pain is part of
life let your pain Punk you
what's that believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn one
of the most common rules successful
people follow let pain fuel you also if
you want to know a dame - Tony Robbins
go where Gopal das and others have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below knowing the one
thing you have to really never do is
compare yourself to other people
absolutely that's the one thing you
can't do it judge the success to someone
else's the fact that human beings our
strongest drive is the need to stay
consistent with how we define ourselves
it's easy to make a buck very hard to
make a difference
[Music]
why's it so hard to fit on yourself for
a lot of people like what's the hardly
why why is that so hard for people to do
to pull it down money in bet on
themselves because when they see it
really works out eventually because
because when you couldn't be a money
that's a struggle and a lot of people
don't just want to walk into a struggle
almost like some people don't even
though they can fight they're not really
you know have the discipline to go to a
training camp and really focus and see
it through and like they don't want to
walk into the to the struggle to win you
have to it to want to link it means you
have to embrace pain you have to embrace
stroke you don't know saying like you
have to know that nothing's gonna be
easy in order to be the best at it in
the world you have to do it and push
yourself from those people want you know
what I'm saying you better be up for
that yeah you know what I'm saying like
you if you up for it you could do it but
not everybody's up for it not everybody
really the intent conceptual evening
when it for doing what the pain it takes
to go get it and I have a lot like these
people that like there's things about
them I don't like but I respect the fact
that they're gonna fight to get what
they want the fight and all as to
whether that our perspective is
different or not they're frightened well
every time whether it's wrong right the
person that fights the hardest plants
you really ultimately know that if you
really believe in yourself and you work
hard at it you'll achieve it the
question is am i ready to work so hard
that I'm better than everyone else
you understand what I'm saying and you
have to answer that question within
yourself am I ready to embrace all the
pain that nobody else wants to embrace
yeah
am I ready to really work harder and do
it so much that I'm better at it than
everyone that does it's really about the
work ethic really it's a professional
work ethic you can't just be good at
something you have to be able to see
things through and do the things that
you don't enjoy it's not really about
the things that you enjoy that's the
easy part it's the things you don't
enjoy that's the things that people
usually shut down
they just don't like it just cuz you
don't like something doesn't mean it's a
failure when I was growing up I went
through a really tough childhood my mom
was a beautiful soul but she abused
prescription drugs and alcohol and
because people have different
personalities in that area and she would
I'm the oldest I have younger brother
five younger sister seven years younger
and she bashed my head against the wall
she think I was lying and she pulled
liquid soap down my throat till I threw
up it was pretty brutal but it made me
become a practical psychologist it made
me have to learn what makes people get
crazy get angry get excited yet love and
I had to learn how to manage her to
protect my brother and sister and to
some extent myself and so you know if my
mom had been the woman I'd hope she'd
been I wouldn't be the man I'm proud to
be so it all worked out in a very
beautiful way but it made me I had so
much suffering in my life I don't want
any human to suffer and I'm F and driven
to end suffering wherever I can possibly
make a difference I don't want to sin
suffering I want them to experience the
joy and the happiness and the freedom
and the love and the opportunity to live
life on their terms but do you have to
fail to be successful yes you have to
have suffering to be successful well you
have to fail I don't know if you have
suffer you know the old phrase you know
pain is part of life suffering is a
choice right unless you go through
sharpening
what does within you will not come out
the pencil has to go through painful
sharpening before the sharp blade comes
out and makes an impact ladies and
gentlemen
similarly in life unless we go through
painful sharpening the best things
within will never come out as they say
no pains no gains I started Google
AdWords in 2001 okay I was I got lucky I
just stumbled and I was one of the first
people to ever use online advertising I
was in I think the second month Google
AdWords launched and there was no
YouTube videos there was no Perry
Marshall books there was there was
nothing you just kind of wasted money to
learn now we're the most spoiled
generation everything this computer on
this phone iPhone 7 is more powerful
than the first rocket that put man on
the moon that cost billions of dollars
now we get that for under a thousand
bucks and people are still like I'm lost
yes your loss
sit down and then open up Safari and go
how to do Google ads and you're gonna
come up let's see what I come up with
AdWords they have their own tutorial
word stream jump if I you got some paid
stuff then you have some free stuff on
HubSpot if you sit in a chair Charlie
Munger calls it assiduity put your ass
in a chair sit there and focus without
being you know the average American
right now the average first in the world
our attention span has dropped to five
seconds the sad news is the average
goldfish has 6 seconds we're now
competing with goldfish and the goldfish
are winning so if you don't have
assiduity to sit down breed there is no
solution for you you will always be poor
because you'll always be beat by
somebody who's willing to sit in the
chair is there a way for people to build
that discipline yes pain and that's why
I'm not a big believer in delusion you
know you asked me one of the rewiring
things we have to do in this world
tell you one you ever heard this myth
everything happens for a reason so just
accept it well there's kind of truth to
that
if I jump off a building and break my
legs yes everything happened for a
reason
the reason was gravity like that's why
you break your legs and physics legs
brittle concrete not brittle so debt but
people interpret everything happens for
a reason be like well I was meant to
learn from that thing and then BS read
Richard Dawkins The Selfish Gene one of
the most important books written in the
last century he says organisms that only
learn through trial and error lose to
organisms that can learn through other
people's a trial and error is anybody
here we got a little live audience
anybody here ever had to be hit by a car
to learn to look both ways I did it I
kind of learned from just somebody
telling me big car two tons velocity
smash dead and I now always look both
ways so if you're myth is that the only
way you're gonna learn is just through
massive mistakes in trial and error you
have a read Richards talking book how
does pain allow somebody to get more
disciplined okay so going back to that
myth of when you see your life and
anytime there should be pain you go no
no no no it was just how it was meant to
be
no look yourself in the mirror sometimes
and go you know why I'm not happy it's
because I didn't listen ten years ago
and I got in the wrong career you know
I'm not happy because I married the
wrong damn person it wasn't meant to
happen yes everything happens for a
reason you made a bad choice but it
didn't have to be that way and the
second you build up pain and this by the
way is not my opinion if you talk to
guys like dr. David buss top ten most
cited psychologist in history okay he's
one of my main mentors he told me I said
to adults change like we do all this
self-help videos and podcasts I said am
I wasting my time he goes yeah kind of I
said why he said well after 25 it's very
hard to teach old dogs new tricks
by the way that's why I've changed
most of my stuff targets people 18 to 25
that's why I do snapchat and all that
because there's hope for 18 to 25 well
now if you're over 25 before you get
depressed he told me but I have good
news for you time I said what he said
adults learn through massive trauma so
you will learn you have to let in some
trauma into your life and that's rough
but no pain no gain like if you are 100
pounds overweight and you want to be
able to play basketball here's my news
for you everything happened for a reason
you got fat cuz you ate too much and you
didn't exercise so welcome to the gym in
the first year is gonna be hell but that
pain hopefully will reprogram your brain
that every time you want to eat that
nasty thing go wait I don't want to go
through that pain again so I think one
of the myths of societies we won't let
pain in we just excuse it all away like
nah that wasn't meant to happen
oh you wasted 20 years of life married
the wrong person in the wrong career no
Tom it wasn't meant to happen
where's the people who go you you wasted
20 years and you will never get it back
you better go in your room and cry and
the truth is you only learn as an adult
unfortunately most people can only
change with mass and trauma I think most
people they don't get what they want in
life because they don't know what they
want
so they lack clarity and why do you lack
motivation chances are they haven't
suffered a lot of pain
you can see now we on a private jet
I remember
many years ago when I was struggling in
business couldn't pay the bills
my father had his first stroke and I was
so much in debt and I couldn't even
afford the plane ticket he was in the
hospital he was an emergency
and I couldn't afford even to buy an
economy ticket because I was in Canada
and he was in Hong Kong that incident
that experience just gave me so much
pain when you have enough pain then your
motivation I said to myself I'll never
ever ever want to live there like that
again
whatever it takes I don't want to
experience so helpless that I couldn't
do anything in order to protect my
family in order to just have the freedom
the ability to divide a plane ticket I
need money I need money when if you want
your kids suffer when your wife needs
money when your family needs money who
the is going to help them if it's not
you and you don't get at that point
well what kind of men are we to me this
is just about raising your standards
every single major breakthrough that you
make in your life and your business will
not come from you just understanding a
certain strategy better is from raising
your standards it's saying where I am
now is not where I am going to be I no
longer accept this situation my living
condition the size of my business is not
acceptable anymore people bombard and
you people picking on you people being a
hater towards you negative people in
your life I no longer accept how people
treat me this is not acceptable anymore
needs to change like it doesn't matter
about the specific strategies it starts
in here it's the mindset it's raising
your standards it's feeling like you
deserve more it's knowing that you
deserve more that you are capable of
great things and you are going to go off
and do it believing in yourself that you
can accomplish this big thing and not
accepting mediocrity anymore that's a
starting point and ok and then so great
raise my standards awesome pay the fare
awesome how do I do it Evan how do I get
it to happen
to me the greatest way to do it is to be
around the people who have the standards
that you want you are a product of your
environment if you're around people who
have bad standards low standards low
self-esteem low self-worth then guess
what you get for yourself you'll get the
same thing you need to be around the
people who have the standards that you
aspire to and the more that you are
hanging around those people the more
it's gonna rub off on you what power
have you found in the darkness first I
would before I answer that question I
want to say about listen to this I'm the
happiest man on the planet Earth so
people may take this and as so many
people do we live in a very weakened
society so when they hear a throwback
guy like me from back in the days of
Garanimals they often think this guy's
just whatever so if you think that I'm
some unhappy guy you're wrong having
lived a life I've lived in seeing the
other side not being afraid to attack
what was in front of me has made me
happy to say that again
in fact let me make sure I understood it
getting to the point where you're not
afraid to face the thing on the other
side of the door that wants to attack
you has made you happy right right it's
really powerful I hope people heard that
right that made me very happy so
basically I just don't walk around with
a daggone smile my face all the time so
you know Merry Christmas but but
basically what the dark side is is we
all have a cookie jar and we all have a
jar that's its official name it's a jar
of man which just it's just ain't going
right and in hell week what they do in
hell week okay this is where I really
went to the dark side we're doing hell
week is a design hell week to find your
flaws and they do a really good job of
that it's 130 hours of continuous
training you may get two hours of sleep
and they beat this study you will find
everything wrong with your mentality and
then they start hell week and that's the
beauty of it and for me I'm not some not
no nasty guy giving guy you know I don't
have a great bit of talent in anything
so what got me through horrible times
was the dark side whereas I created my
name is David Goggins I created Goggins
Goggins is the guy that can take
anything you put in front of them you
want to break my legs so be it
I have a way of going to a place I could
did in that race where all the pain and
suffering that they put on top of me in
hell week I will reverse that pain and
suffering and I will take your soul so
every instructor that put me through
buds my job what drove me was I wanted
you to go home that night after you beat
the living [ __ ] out of me and I smiled
in your face I wanted you to feel worse
than I did and you were going home to a
nice warm bed with your wife or your
kids and a nice meal and I was still out
there in the grip suffering for another
I want you to think about me knowing
that I'm comfortable being very
uncomfortable and I want you to think
about when you went through hell week
how uncomfortable you weren't how bad
you wanted to quit knowing I'm not
thinking that way so the dark side is
something that I've designed it's an
evil place I can go that very few things
can hurt me
I used to hurt you're trying to put on
me I flip it upside down and use it you
try use it for Kryptonite know its power
pillars for me I'm using it for strength
I flip negative into positive Sartre is
the transitions going to be hard I'm not
gonna lie to you go from being on the
block going to be a high school dropout
to getting a GED is not the transition
is not easy in order for you to go from
running level to the next level in order
for any woman to transition for any man
to transition the thing that they want
must be greater than the thing they
fairly had you only go to another level
when you roll when you own this level
and you eat not a trash cans and you say
enough is enough when you live in an
abandoned buildings in the winter and
you say enough
you only transition from one level to
the next when you tie to the level you
are you keep telling me this happened in
your life and that's happened in your
life and it who is happening to
everybody do you let your pain Punk you
you let your pain make you quit you
thinking special you think you don't
only want we all go through I'm just
gonna give some out of mine so you gonna
have to go through it just like
everybody else you gonna have to pay the
fear sweat blow tears but guess what
when you walk across that stage it's
gonna have that much more meaningful you
said that every great change starts with
pain and I found that really intriguing
it feels dark it feels heavy when you
say that but it's that's where my
experience that it's accurate is that
the reason people change is because of
pain the reason we grow is because we
get uncomfortable and we embrace being
uncomfortable but being honest with the
pain that we feel is usually the prime
mover for people to do the work that is
necessary to push to the edge
so there's a difference between pain and
suffering there is a difference between
there where we're all suffering we all
have suffering we all have an emptiness
or a dark place or corners inside of our
spirit in our mind that are not
fulfilled and watered and full like we
we all can relate to that and when I'm
talking about pain I'm not necessarily
talking about suffering but
acknowledging our suffering being in
touch with the pain that's enough to say
when you're really honest that's enough
to say I can't do this I don't want to
do this anymore like this is not the
person I want to become and be on a
regular basis if that's the case if that
assumption is right then as a loved one
my job is to help you get real and
experience those places as often as you
can
so that you make that the declaration to
say no no that's not okay for me to feel
and be this way on a regular basis so
let me pull on that thread just a little
bit further it is healthy and necessary
to feel all of the human emotions but we
ask people what do you want in life most
people say I want to be happy wait hold
on now if grandma dies do you want to be
happy that's it like really when your
child is sick do you want to be happy no
no I think the answer is that we want to
feel all of the human experience to its
fullest but never lose ourself in it but
to experience all of it and so we're
getting into the weeds of some very
esoteric and non scientific thinking
right now but the practice is that if I
care about you deeply the mistake I can
make in your life is to help you feel
like it's all okay like oh it's okay
it's okay that you're drinking and
driving and you killed a
fourteen-year-old that's no problem like
you'll do better next time
no the work is to say well what's this
like for you to feel that pain so you
make the commitment to say no no I can't
do this anymore and that's when it
becomes really real I did a lot of my
growing up in Hawaii and all my
as family I was evicted out of Hawaii we
were picked it out of our little
efficiency forced to move it forced to
leave Hawaii
my grandfather years ago bought the
wrestling promotion in Hawaii
and
if he struggled with it he died
struggling my grandmother took over the
wrestling promotion she became the first
woman promoter and pro wrestling in a
very cutthroat shark infested the world
and anyway
Hawaii is always represented so much
struggle I started getting arrested when
I was 14 years old
there's a lot of stupid I should have
been doing I would at that time when we
got evicted out of our efficiency I
thought it was the worst thing that
could ever happen and actually at that
time it was but now in hindsight it was
the greatest thing to ever happen
because it forced me into this mindset
honestly the hard work it sounds like if
I could do anything I will do everything
I can to make sure we never get evicted
again and anyway that kind of mentality
drives me today
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Robin Sharma on how to transform
your pain into power but before that
it's time for the three-point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your life or your
business and if you're feeling bold
answer these questions in the comments
below here we go question number one
what is the most painful thing that you
have been through number two how can you
use it to serve others and number three
what is your why
every great hero was broken if you were
look at Nelson Mandela
he suffered more than most people if you
look at mother Teresa she went through
incredible adversity over the course of
her journey if you were to study Mahatma
Gandhi Nelson Mandela Rosa Parks
Shakespeare and Tolstoy if you look at
any great artist a Picasso jean-michel
Basquiat if you look at the great world
builders they all suffered let me put it
to you this way with great love and
respect they all out suffered the
majority and what I'm suggesting to you
is pain can be transformed into power
with the intention to transform pain
into power you see what most people do
is this is why most good people lose
they stumble and they fall and they
become heartbroken or disappointed by
life's challenges that happens to every
single one of us I mean just to be very
authentic as I always want to be in
these mastery sessions episodes I've
gone through a lot of hardship in my
life when I was you know going through
school very few people believed in me
and I was dismissed and called very very
average and the principal at the school
I was at said you're not even gonna get
into University and you might know my
backstory on the monk who sold his
Ferrari but that was a self-published
book and I was at the American
Booksellers conference in Chicago with a
cover of one of my books over my around
my neck shaking hands with all the
agents that were coming up the escalator
and when I was a self-published author
and I used to go into bookstores and say
would you take three copies of my book
I'll sign them could you put it on the
shelf and I was treated rudely and I was
laughed at and I was on radio shows and
I was ridiculed and then I've gone
through a lot of personal pain in my own
life and I've been on the top of the
mountain of victory and I must tell you
I have walked the lonely path in the
darkness in the valley of darkness but
rumi the great philosopher said it so
beautifully he said allow your heart to
be broken over and over and over until
it opens and what I'm suggesting to you
is really to dial into this insight all
great heroes have been broken but rather
than blaming 27 years in imprisonment in
the case of Nelson Mandela rather than
blaming his naysayers and his detractors
in the case of mahathma gandhi rather
than saying life is hard why isn't isn't
greatness easy in the case of a mother
Teresa or Martin Luther King jr. rather
than saying why did this happen to me in
the case of Rosa Parks who refused to
give up her seat to someone on a bus
because she was being treated like a
second-class citizen because of the
color of her skin these great ones all
had one thing in common they leveraged
their pain and the power they turned
their tragedies into victories if you
have to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would become like a little beacon
if you want to know what's stopping you
from getting success I highly recommend
the video right there next to me go
check it out continue to believe and
I'll see you there oh I'll believe it
when I see it it's like I'll see it when
I believe it if you really analyze your
beliefs you'll change